[Musique]
un nouveau club de danse a ouvert à
montigny des cours de flamenco sont
proposés à la maison de quartier andré
malraux par l'association passion
lyonnais qui a été créée en juillet 2018
c'est tout récent et nous avons un
plateau avec nous la présidente de
l'association est aussi la costumière
marie cayla est aussi conçu et le
gaillard de la vice présidente de
l'association bonjour mesdames
comment avez-vous eu l'idée de créer
l'association passion violée en fait on
est toutes les deux
danseuse de flamenco fait on est toutes
les deux aficionados comme on dit en
espagne et on prenait des cours de
flamenco assez loin on a eu envie de
créer sa sueur montigny-le-bretonneux
parce que j'en avais pas on avait des
copines qui voulant faire avec nous mais
qui pouvaient pas se déplacer aussi loin
donc voilà comme ça on a créé
l'association c'est dire on se lance et
puis on a pas mal de monde qui est
intéressé on a pas mal de nouvelles donc
on est assez contente de de notre
réussite pour l'instant on espère avoir
encore plus de gens et merci à vous de
nous avoir son plateau ce soir alors des
cours pour débutants sont proposés le
mercredi de 18h30 à 20h tandis que les
initiés sont attendus de 20h à 21h30 à
la maison de quartier andré malraux et
justement j'ai testé un nouveau cours
avec la professeur de danse vanessa bar
kita je vous laisse découvrir
je me trouve à qui rend la salle
andré-malraux
montigny le bretonneux et vous l'aurez
compris je vais tester de flamenco et
danse originaire d'espagne
olé
[Musique]
vanessa je me trouve actuellement dans
votre cours de flamenco vous êtes
professeur de flamenco depuis combien de
temps ça fait quinze ans que j'enseigne
et qu'est ce qui est plus dur dans cette
danse de manier les bras les hanches les
pieds en le bénéficie c
est arrivé
les bras et les pieds parce que dans les
mouvements des bras on va très justement
par rapport aux pieds qu'on accélère
donc on va pas la même vitesse
c'est ça qui est très compliqué pour les
élèves et pour les pieds c'est les pieds
c'est la rapidité
non
et on accélère balle sont périmés
travail paraît que les bras et c'est une
danse qui est accessible à tout le monde
oui à tout le monde aux hommes aux
femmes aux enfants c'est donc ça se
danse en couple ou seul face à sedan
tout seul en couple ce sera normalement
le joli ces femmes et yann est encore
chaude à 3,4 très bien mais je vais
essayer tout ça vamos dame à paris
[Musique]
ouais
alors vanessa c'est quoi les mouvements
de base les mouvements de base ce qui
est important quand on tient bien agi
pour l'un tient bien au bout on va
mettre à la taille les pôles vers le bas
de coude vers le haut et le bus en avant
d'accord et ce qui est important c'est
les frappes qu'enfin on pointe et enfin
aux frappes lointaines et ont frappé
trois fois on fait sa troisième et
lampes et 4 en 1 2 3 4 est en pilote et
on repense revoir les colonnes arrière
et le buste en avant et on fait ce rap
on pointe frappe en pointe
on pointe quatre lits plats 1 2 3 4 et
on change
dans 204 on n'oublie pas le bras 1 2 3 4
des changements ont fait 1 2 3 4 et là
oui ça va c'est juste les pieds la rater
et après quelques entraînements c'est
parti pour la chorégraphie avec le
chapeau
[Musique]
non
on
j'étais fort et le flamenco france est
notre focus que je m'entraîne un peu sur
la rapidité des pieds allez je retourne
le flamenco est un art espagnol qui se
compose de trois pratiques artistiques
la guitare le chant et la danse comme
vous l'avez vu depuis sa naissance et
arrêt lié à l'histoire aux traditions
andalouses
il occupe aujourd'hui une place
importante dans cette culture régionale
marie conçue et l'eau vous allez nous
danser la sévillane
quelle est l'histoire de cette danse
alors la sévillane fait partie du
folklore andalou
elle se compose de quatre petites danses
d'une minute à peu près chacune qui
raconte en fait la rencontre amoureuse
donc la première c'est la rencontre la
deuxième la séduction la troisième
dispute est la quatrième et la
réconciliation
on vous montre tout ça tout de suite
place à la danse
[Musique]
tu y vas de pellegrini egoitz de la
maman
oui
mais confie t elle à mano
rien n'est fait reclinghem et rory
lamont
les comparer le nombre et méchoui
[Musique]
sourit t à la radio oui ma bonne dame
m
médina
[Musique]
mam inoubliable
aussi tout le mépris non
[Musique]
mais temprano
hélas
il y a
ok d'amendé mais les parties des mollahs
ont fait d'avoir été
à
[Musique]
mais aussi la porte à personne
si la rébellion
rival sens
ce format
m
non mais
vers minuit
mais quand des centrales à la finance
[Applaudissements]
vous allez je vous ai ramené je vous ai
ramené quelques cobayes vous a ramené
quelques cobayes micalet voilà je les
laisse moi je vais observer cela de loin
aujourd'hui vous avez mon courage et au
miel alors donc on va danser par deux
parties avec marie toi tu tenais à être
moi mais là et qui dansent mason alors
parcours donc on sait les petits pas de
bases même pied même là on commence par
les pieds gauches fait cinq fois
alors les amis vous qu'il soit très
viril il serait tombé de son avant hier
comme ça c'est moi qui étais bombay
bombay
sur un arrière très bien ici on fait des
jours de 10h à 17 les mains pour jeter
les poignées balles à blanc ne bouge pas
trop mauvaise que sa clémence est
d'accord je reste statique d'accord ces
dernières ont fait les pas de base
mon cas avec manon d'un petit peu bu
sans doute à l'heure on essaye on essaye
un grand a c'est bien tout ça va devoir
répondre à ça attention après ça la
touche à tout chez soi on se pensait
nous passe et pas de base à lui à gauche
j'y reviens sur les bras c'est ça qu'on
pense qu marché qui fait que taper dans
un ballon si je tape vraiment ça
un petit coup de valence
lité nikkei
[Musique]